Speaker 1: let's try Alex from Baltimore.
Alex, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right.
Hey, how are you doing?
I like to actually have a question about history
and how other as well traveled person as you
are, how other cultures see their history.
OK, because at least on more left leaning
people in the United States.
They read about American history and a lot
of it is shameful, but and then they personally
become scheme.
They say they're ashamed to be an American
in this country is nothing but evil and racist.
I was just curious, how do you like European
people feel about such things?
Because they certainly have a bad history
of colonialism and atrocities to native people.
Are you aware of anything like that?
Speaker 1: I don't.
I mean, listen, so I know Europeans from the
UK, from Spain, from France, from Italy, which
has less of a colonial history from Belgium,
which has quite a colonial history.
So on, so forth.
Germany, you know, I what I can tell you is
all the Germans I know feel really bad about
the history of Nazism and they sort of go
out of their way to distance and to talk about
how they completely denounce it when it comes
to places like U.K., France, Spain, which
also have and Belgium, which have colonial
histories.
It's just never been a topic of conversation.
It's a great question how much of their identity
in their country as as a someone from their
country is tied up in the colonial history?
It's never come up.
And I don't know what that tells us, but you'd
have to really ask them.
Speaker 2: That's fair, I just I'm just kind
of in the middle of those two, I still consider
myself to be proud to be an American because
there's a lot of good things.
But I don't feel the coat, the terrible things
we've done either.
Just, you know,
Speaker 1: as a naturalized American, I don't
really use the term proud one way or the other.
I don't say I'm proud or that I'm that there's
an absence.
I just think about it more like, you know,
my family moved here because the economic
situation was terrible in Argentina.
And it's not a thing of pride.
But I'm aware that at the time there was an
economic opportunity here that didn't exist
in Argentina.
And I believe as an individual, I've benefited
drastically from growing up in the U.S. rather
than Argentina.
Like I'm without question, I'm financially
orders of magnitude better off because of
that.
Does that make me.
It's not about proud.
It's I recognize the opportunity that I got
and I'm glad for it, you know.
Does that make sense?
Speaker 2: That's that's totally fair.
I guess I could fall in that myself.
That makes sense.
And I do have a quick, silly food debate question
for you, please.
I'm going to ask you, do you prefer coffee
or tea?
But.
The whichever one you pick, the other one
is completely vaporized off the face of the
earth.
OK, I never did get to get.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I, I prefer coffee,
I guess if he were vapourised, I'd have lemonade.
Speaker 2: I don't despair.
Yeah, I always said I prefer to see if it
had the same caffeine content as coffee, but
that's just me.
Speaker 1: OK.
All right.
Very good.
Well, I'm glad we were able to sort that out.
Speaker 2: Yes.
Thank you.
All right.
Have a good day.
Speaker 1: First question was excellent.
Excellent, excellent.
First question.
Let's focus on the positive there, please,
my friends.
OK, thank you to everybody who called.
I'm sorry.
I can't get to more people today, but we do
have a time limit and we will take calls again
very, very soon.